[Music]
um so yeah let's go into the death
anxiety yeah I don't know man I just
I've always had it it's a weird thing
I used to ride my bike to elementary
school and I would I would wake up as a
kid and be like I'm gonna die today and
then I would very meticulously
I would wake up really early to
so because there'd be less Street
traffic and then I would like uh
cross the street at very precise times
because I knew there'd be no cars and
just weird as [ __ ] like that so so and
this is this is when something big is
coming up big or just it can happen on a
random day sometimes I just stay in the
house because you're scared you're gonna
die it's a lot of superstition yeah it's
it's a weird thing it's it's not
happened a lot recently
I've not gotten this feeling for a
minute but yeah because I think I'm
doing something so major I got this when
we went on the road too
it's like the biggest polar vortex that
I was like on my phone oh yeah yeah oh
true yeah
so but it'll be fine
it'll be okay
yeah you're gonna be good I get that too
sometimes I was like just random like oh
[ __ ] what if like just random thoughts
like that yeah it's more it's intrusive
though what if that's the last thing I
ever say yeah you know [ __ ] like what is
it like the last bonus episode we do
yeah uh yeah that scares the [ __ ] out of
me yeah this is off to a good start what
in the [ __ ] is this
yeah yes absolutely
what do we get
all right folks we got a little package
here this is a PR thing or what is this
it just came I don't know I mean
looks like you already opened it well I
opened the box because I wanted to see
what it was was it addressed to you oh
yeah
okay
this is uh
whoa this is
kind of sick
this is from YouTube whoa
I've got a record player it's a record
player is this a vinyl of us I guess
it's been kind of chill working with you
try not to fall off next year L ratio
garyvee owns you sincerely and thank you
Andrew appreciate it good to know
good to know our rep at YouTube really
likes us oh it's Bob Marley and the
Whalers
so he gave us a record player
um this is sick well we can like blaze
up some kush
yeah
right oh yeah
oh you pull it out
is that what you do
we're not very good at that yeah well
Cody likes to go raw so I don't know wow
yeah so yeah any oh Ryan you know just
bring trash in and leave it
I'll write you a gift
yeah most of it was trash yeah
if we're going off percentages I mean
this is mostly garbage
[Laughter]
nice dude that would have been really
funny if it hit you in the face
you know
oh I'm guys I'm being mean here but
trust me I'm
Rich yeah
trust me I'm I'm way worse than this
one of the funniest things was me
bullying Alex on my channel and someone
said
I don't know what was giving me like
David dobrik Vibes because is that when
you were beating the [ __ ] out of him
yeah no we didn't post that one yeah
would you say we didn't post that oh
that's just for fun yeah no it was the
one where I tied him like arms down on a
motorcycle and I just sent it off into
the distance
I said balance
yeah your life depends on it he's in the
front seat of a car yeah okay now I'm
gonna put this Boulder on the gas pedal
yeah okay
no I actually made him drive under a
bridge many times I just kept dropping
rocks and I'm like don't get hit
don't get hit that feels like an iPhone
game doesn't it yeah yeah yeah drop the
rocks on the boulder drop yeah
that's that's grim
um I hate this bad liver King meets
hasbullah like it's just [ __ ] just
that's what the internet is now just
like PR
just PR headlines look how
relatable I am liver King meets
Hezbollah oh we gotta see that yeah I
kind of do have to see that
I kind of want to see it okay because I
love hasblah oh look at them
don't forget that I'm coming for you
I'd rather take a picture with a dog
doesn't even look him in the eye
yeah he really doesn't respect him yeah
that's crazy
he's like I thought you were Natty dog
Livery King just down on one knee like
look at him what a humiliating moment
yeah
seriously yo I'm a big fan I'd rather
take a picture with a dog
okay for show I'm naked here I'm pretty
close with the thing on here it's like
shut up wolf head thing headdress
what a man how do you even respond to
that yeah that's pretty crazy
what if he just took him
just took him and like threw him like
me
you're gonna take a picture all right
cool
let's see how it is
grab somebody's ankles [ __ ] up holds
him upside down Jesus Christ dude Jesus
Christ
what's liver King steroid joke never
came here oh yeah I saw this
it's amazing
[Music]
God damn
what a perfect response
100 out of 10 on that young lady holy
[ __ ]
amazing I just want to be as transparent
as I can be
okay she's like just trying to do my job
thank you all right wrote me into your
[ __ ] [ __ ] please all right just
trying to do my job all right please
stop filming me
dude
look at this side profile of liver King
liver Queen's face
just egging on this bit yeah
yeah you get it right yeah that's the
funniest part is they both found out
right here that they're not actually
that famous
[Laughter]
what do you mean
liver King here and I'm on steroids and
she's like don't know who you are you
cannot come in here without putting a
shirt on yeah
sign right there no shirt no shoes man
was that video supposed to make me feel
like he's being more transparent because
like that's kind of the feeling I get
yeah yeah same ice cool yeah it's cool
how it's like self-aware and he kind of
Embraces what people were you know kind
of upset with him about yeah that's fun
yeah
I'm just kidding he [ __ ] sucks